aquí quiero enseñarles a resolver un
problema un poco más sofisticado de
fuerza centrípeta y este es un problema
clásico aquí tenemos una masa que está
atada a una cuerda que a su vez está
atada al techo y a esta masa se le da
una rapidez inicial y va a girar en un
círculo horizontal esta masa va a
mantener una altura constante no va a
estar cambiando su altura va a estar
dando vueltas en un círculo horizontal y
si observan esto desde arriba o desde
abajo se verá como un círculo perfecto
en donde esta masa estará dando vueltas
y vueltas y aquí tenemos dos preguntas
que resolver tenemos que encontrar la
atención de esta cuerda y encontrar la
rapidez de esta pelota y aquí nos dan
estos datos
tenemos que esta masa es de 3 kilogramos
la longitud de la cuerda es de 2 metros
y esta cuerda va a estar girando con un
ángulo de 30 grados con respecto a esta
línea que coincide con el centro de este
círculo
y este es un problema clásico por una
buena razón ya que si no tenemos bien
claros los conceptos involucrados aquí
con la fuerza centrípeta y no tenemos
una estrategia para solucionar este tipo
de problemas al tratar de resolver este
problema se van a hacer evidentes
nuestras fallas aquí vamos a clarificar
estos conceptos que involucran la fuerza
centrípeta y además vamos a ver la
estrategia a seguir no solo para
resolver problemas de fuerza centrípeta
sino cualquier problema que involucre
fuerzas esta estrategia es la siguiente
lo primero que hay que hacer es dibujar
un buen diagrama de fuerzas dibujar un
diagrama
de fuerzas
cuáles son las fuerzas que actúan en
esta masa de 3 kilogramos una de las
fuerzas que actúa aquí es la fuerza de
gravedad que nos jala directamente hacia
abajo y para encontrar esta fuerza de
gravedad usamos la fórmula de masa por
jeques 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y el otro objeto que está
tocando a esta masa es esta cuerda por
lo que voy a tener aquí mi fuerza de
tensión está la denominamos usando una t
mayúscula que representa la fuerza total
de tensión que está actuando en esta
cuerda y el segundo paso y último de
esta estrategia es usar la segunda ley
de newton
pero solo hay que aplicarla en una
dirección cada vez y típicamente tenemos
solo dos direcciones esta dirección
vertical o esta dirección horizontal y
tenemos una probabilidad del 50% de
elegir la dirección correcta tenemos que
elegir una de las direcciones y aquí no
hay problema de elegir la dirección
incorrecta si eligiéramos la dirección
incorrecta nos daríamos cuenta porque
tendríamos demasiadas variables y no
podríamos resolverlas pero lo que
hayamos escrito para resolver esa parte
nos va a servir nos va a servir para
nuestros cálculos usando la otra
dirección así que no borran los cálculos
que hayan hecho si es que eligieron la
dirección incorrecta simplemente hagan
los cálculos para la otra dirección aquí
yo ya sé cuál es la dirección correcta
porque ya he resuelto este tipo de
problemas antes pero de no ser así lo
peor que podemos hacer es quedarnos sin
saber qué hacer
tenemos que intentar estos cálculos con
alguna dirección
cualquiera que sea que elijamos
no pasa nada si nos equivocamos
solamente tenemos otra dirección que
elegir
busque a alguien dice que la dirección a
elegir es la vertical así que vamos a
tener nuestra aceleración en la
dirección vertical que es igual a la
fuerza neta que está actuando sobre este
objeto en esta dirección
entre la masa de este objeto y ahora me
pregunto cuál es la aceleración en la
dirección vertical algunas personas
podrían pensar que es 9.8 o menos 9.8
pero esto sólo sería correcto si esta
bola estuviera en caída libre y en este
caso esta bola no está en caída libre al
contrario no está cambiando su altura
vertical permanece en una altura
constante por lo que aquí no hay una
velocidad vertical y por lo tanto
tampoco va a haber una aceleración
vertical ya que esta pelota no se está
moviendo verticalmente así que del lado
izquierdo de nuestra igualdad va a haber
un ser los cero son geniales nos
facilitan mucho los cálculos
y cuál va a ser la fuerza neta en la
dirección vertical aquí vamos a poner la
fuerza de gravedad porque
definitivamente es una fuerza vertical
pero aquí hay que tener cuidado si vamos
a considerar la dirección hacia abajo
como negativa y hacia arriba como
positiva esta fuerza de gravedad va a
ser negativa porque apunta hacia abajo
cuando estamos trabajando con la
dirección vertical la convención típica
es que las direcciones hacia abajo son
negativas y las que van hacia arriba son
positivas y ahora nos preguntamos hay
alguna otra fuerza vertical aquí pues lo
que tenemos que hacer es ver nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas para eso lo
dibujamos ya que aquí nos va a decir si
hay alguna otra fuerza vertical y la
única otra fuerza vertical es esta y
sólo una parte de esta fuerza de tensión
es la que va en la fórmula no puedo
poner toda la fuerza de tensión aquí
porque no toda esta es la dirección
completamente vertical pero no es así
la parte está vertical y otra parte está
horizontal una parte de esta fuerza de
atención está aquí en dirección
horizontal y a este componente le voy a
llamar la fuerza de atención en la
dirección horizontal de x y parte de
esta atención tendrá un componente
vertical y a éste le voy a llamar el
componente vertical de ella por lo que
solo puedo incluir ese componente
vertical en nuestra fórmula ya que es el
único que tiene la dirección vertical
así que aquí puedo escribir masters pero
no lo voy a hacer porque lo que me
preguntan este la atención no el
componente vertical de esta así que lo
quitamos quiero escribir mi tesis en
términos de t y cómo puedo hacerlo bueno
vemos que aquí se está formando un
triángulo y este ángulo es el mismo que
el que está formando la cuerda con esta
línea vertical la atención no es
acuerda la atención es la fuerza
ejercida por la cuerda en la masa y
aunque la atención tiene la misma
dirección que la cuerda la atención no
es la cuerda y este es un error muy
común muchas personas dicen pues la
atención va a ser igual a los dos metros
es correcto no esto ni siquiera es una
fuerza así que no vamos a incluir esto
aquí
así que aunque la atención tiene la
misma dirección que la cuerda no es lo
mismo sin embargo el ángulo que forma la
cuerda con esta línea vertical va a ser
el mismo ángulo que tendremos aquí 30
grados y ahora puedo poner el componente
vertical en términos de la atención y
del ángulo este es un triángulo
rectángulo y este lado es el lado
adyacente a este ángulo de 30 grados por
lo tanto vamos a usar el cose no decimos
que el coseno de teta es igual al lado
adyacente
entre la hipotenusa
a veces algunas personas se confunden
diciendo bueno es que este lado es el
que está vertical y yo pensé que siempre
el lado vertical es el opuesto y sería
el opuesto si el ángulo que usáramos
fuera este pero este no lo conocemos el
ángulo que conocemos es este y este es
el lado adyacente a este ángulo
conocemos el ángulo por lo que podemos
decir que el coseno de 30 grados es
igual al lado adyacente que este eje
entre la hipotenusa que esté y en muchas
personas esto los confunde ya que les
parece que tenemos muchas variables pero
esto está bien vamos a etiquetar estate
como nuestra hipotenusa y vamos a hacer
algunas manipulaciones para poder
encontrarte si multiplicamos ambos lados
por t y nos queda que tg es igual a t
por el coseno de 30 grados
y esto es lo que voy a poner en mi
fuerza neta vertical voy a poner más ya
que la dirección es hacia arriba t por
el coseno de 30 grados y ahora sólo
tengo que dividir todo esto entre mi
masa y ahora tengo que despejar t
multiplicó por m a ambos lados de la
igualdad m por 0 sigue siendo 0 y voy a
sumar m g en ambos lados y me va a
quedar que t es igual a m por g positivo
/
el coseno de 30 grados si ponemos
números nos queda que t es igual a tres
kilogramos por 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado entre el coseno de 30 grados lo
que nos da una tensión de 33.9 newtons
que voy a redondear a 34 newtons y esta
es la atención que yo quiero encontrar
en esta cuerda ya encontramos esto ahora
vamos a encontrar la rapidez y aquí
algunas personas dicen bueno que voy a
hacer no se preocupen no se desvíen de
la estrategia dibujamos nuestro diagrama
de fuerzas y vamos a usar la segunda ley
de newton en una dirección y tenemos
trabajo que hacer pues vamos a usar la
segunda ley de newton para la otra
dirección así que vamos a usar esto pero
en la dirección x por lo que digo que mi
aceleración en la dirección horizontal
es igual a la fuerza neta
esta dirección horizontal entre la masa
y ahora me pregunto lo mismo hay alguna
aceleración en la dirección horizontal
cuando teníamos la dirección vertical
vimos que no había aceleración y quizás
podríamos pensar que en la dirección
horizontal tampoco va a haber pero si
nos fijamos aquí nuestra masa se va a
mover circularmente por lo que aquí
habrá una aceleración centrípeta por lo
que esta dirección horizontal realmente
va a ser la dirección centrípeta y
siempre que nos encontremos la
aceleración centrípeta podremos
reemplazarla con b al cuadrado entre el
radio de la ruta circular y esto va a
ser igual a la fuerza centrípeta neta
sobre esta masa
y cuáles son las fuerzas centrípetas en
esta dirección puede ser a la fuerza que
esté actuando en la dirección x en la
dirección horizontal la dirección
horizontal es aquella que resulta que
esté apuntando hacia el centro del
círculo y es por eso que la dirección
aquí es la dirección centrípeta y si yo
quiero conocer cuáles son las fuerzas
centrípetas me fijo en mi diagrama de
fuerzas de manera que con sólo verlo
puedo identificar cuáles son las fuerzas
que actúan verticalmente y también
cuáles son las fuerzas horizontales y
centrípetas y la única fuerza que tiene
esta dirección horizontal es este
componente de la atención tx pero
nuevamente en lugar de poner
directamente esta tx aquí la vamos a
poner pero en términos de la atención
total y del ángulo de la misma manera
que lo hicimos aquí que es igual a t por
el coseno de 30 grados por lo que no nos
debe de sorprender
que nuestro componente horizontal tx sea
igual a t por el seno de 30 grados y si
no me creen pueden probarlo usando las
fórmulas trigonométricas este componente
tx es el lado opuesto al ángulo y el
lado opuesto involucra al seno podemos
decir que el seno de 30 grados es igual
a el lado opuesto que esté x entre la
hipotenusa que éste y si despejamos la t
vamos a multiplicar t en ambos lados de
la ecuación y nos queda que te x es
igual a t por el seno de 30 grados
así que ponemos esto en nuestra fórmula
ya que sabemos que la única fuerza que
está actuando en el sentido horizontal
es esta entonces aquí ponemos t por el
seno
de 30 grados no hay ninguna otra fuerza
que esté actuando en la dirección
horizontal y ahora se pueden dar cuenta
de él porque no elegí esta dirección
primero ya que desconozco esta velocidad
y mi interrogante es atención t
solamente porque elegimos primero la
dirección vertical es que pudimos
encontrar la atención y ahora sí con
este dato de la atención puedo encontrar
la rapidez ya que ya conozco esta t así
que ahora pongo esta atención de 34
newtons aquí y puedo encontrar la
rapidez pero aquí hay otro error muy
común las personas siempre quieren poner
aquí en lugar de la r los dos metros
porque dicen bueno tú me estás dando
aquí estos dos metros pues los voy a
usar voy a usarlos
ya que esto es cierto no esto no es r
cuando estamos trabajando con la fórmula
de aceleración centrípeta está r se
refiere al radio de la ruta circular que
está siguiendo este objeto pero este
objeto no se está moviendo en un círculo
que tenga un radio de 2 metros este
objeto se está moviendo en un círculo
que tiene un radio más o menos así y
cuánto va a medir este radio del círculo
bueno si queremos encontrarlo vamos a
formar un triángulo rectángulo pero
ahora tendremos el triángulo con
referencia a la longitud de la cuerda no
es con respecto a la atención sino con
respecto a la longitud de la cuerda
este es un triángulo rectángulo
conocemos el ángulo y este lado que es
el radio
es el lado opuesto al ángulo por lo que
vamos a usar el seno de theta podemos
decir que el seno de eta que es de 30
grados es igual al lado opuesto que es r
entre la hipotenusa que es la longitud
de la cuerda que es el así que si quiero
conocer r voy a despejarlo multiplicando
a ambos lados por l y me va a quedar que
r es igual a él por el seno de 30 grados
así que el radio de este círculo es el
que es esta longitud de la cuerda de 2
metros por el seno de 30 grados
ahora vamos a usar esto en la fórmula y
nos va a quedar d al cuadrado entre r
pero r encontramos
que es l por el seno de 30 grados que es
igual a t por el seno de 30 grados entre
la masa si despejamos de cuadrada nos va
a quedar que b cuadrada es igual a t por
el seno de 30 grados por l por el seno
de 30 grados
todo esto dividido entre la masa y como
quiero conocer la rapidez no la rapidez
al cuadrado puede sacar la raíz cuadrada
en ambos lados de esta igualdad de
manera que me queda que la rapidez es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de todo esto si
ponemos los números nos queda que esto
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de t que es
34 newtons por el seno de 30 grados x l
son estos dos metros por el seno de 30
grados completo esto de aquí todo esto
dividido entre la masa de 3 kilogramos
todo esto nos da una rapidez de 2.38 que
voy a redondear a 2.4 metros por segundo
que es la rapidez que tratamos de
encontrar en resumen cuando tratamos de
resolver un problema sofisticado de
fuerza centrípeta asegúrense de dibujar
un buen diagrama de fuerzas y después
apliquen la segunda ley de newton para
una sola dirección y sólo usen fuerzas
que estén en esa dirección para la
fuerza neta y si la dirección elegida
resulta estar en la dirección centrípeta
es decir que apunta hacia el centro del
círculo entonces podremos usar b al
cuadrado entre r en lugar de nuestra
aceleración centrípeta pero nuevamente
solo tenemos que incluir aquellas
fuerzas que están en esa dirección para
la fuerza centrípeta y asegúrese de
comprender de qué es
r el radio del que hablamos es el radio
de la ruta circular en la que está
viajando el objeto